there's a theory within at least the
spiritual Community or like spiritual
thoughts that time is speeding up is
there any way that's possible
well I can talk directly from the
physics of the situation and I would say
there is resonance and that time is much
more fluid than we would think based on
everyday experience right everyday
experience seems to suggest that you're
watching my watch and everybody's watch
if it's a properly functioning watch
they're all tick and tough time in the
same rate that's so all there is to it
and from a practical standpoint that's
pretty much true which is why it's what
we experience but from a physics
standpoint it's absolutely not true
because as I made reference to before if
you and I are moving relative to each
other our watches are not taking up time
at the same rate
um if I go to the top of a tall building
even on planet Earth my watch will be
taking off time a little bit more
quickly than clock sitter down on the
surface because I'm experiencing less
gravity and the less gravity you
experience the more quickly your clock
will tick compared to a clock that's
experiencing more gravity so in that
sense time speeds up it slows down
depending upon the gravity you
experience and the speed with which you
are moving but on planet Earth most of
us are pretty much moving at the same
speed yeah the only speed that matters
in this context is the speed of light
light travels so quickly that it's well
beyond any experience it goes 300
million meters per second it can go
around the entire Earth more than seven
times in one second
seven times around the Earth in one
second now if you can achieve those
speeds then the difference in your watch
and my watch would become manifest we
would see we would measure the
difference between those but on planet
Earth how fast do you go 100 miles an
hour
240 miles an hour like did I age more or
less going 240 miles an hour that's
right it's so it's so tiny we were
talking in the billions and the
trillionths of a second difference that
it's irrelevant from a practical
standpoint so from a practical
perspective no time is not spinning up
it's not slowing down it is the same for
all of us on planet Earth from a cosmic
and I don't mean like new agey cosmic I
mean from the cosmic perspective of how
time behaves in the universe there is no
universal clock there is no one time
that we are all Tethered to clocked tick
off time depending on how they move and
the gravity they experience
do you remember an Interstellar
I love this my favorite
oh good so do remember when um the
Matthew McConaughey and the other
um uh actor I can't remember her name
sorry apology yeah Anne Hathaway exactly
go down that planet right and and there
are other uh companion back on the ship
I forget his name yep when they return
they were down there for like four hours
and he's aged 23 years yes okay this is
how science actually works that was not
Hollywood nonsense if you go near a
black hole the gravity is powerful that
slows the ticking of time on your watch
compared to the watch that's on the ship
far away from the black hole and so a
few hours for you on that planet near
the black hole would be something like
23 years for someone back on the ship
there you have time speeding up slowing
down right there and that that's
accurate yeah so that is it's real it's
just so minuscule here but it's real
it's just and this is how numbers this
is how scientists and physicists are
able to make calculations is that you
look at the small to get the big right
exactly that was that was the power of
Einstein you put your finger right on it
he would see a little crack in the
mathematics that wouldn't be relevant
for experience here on planet Earth but
he would push the mathematics forward
and reveal what that crack in our
understanding would mean through the
entirety of the cosmos and indeed he was
the one that found that time ticks off
at different rates depending on the
gravitational field so as time Dimension
that exists in the entire universe I
think so I think that's a reasonable way
of putting it it perhaps is less
mysterious than it might sound I mean
when we talk about Dimension It's
usually the data necessary to specify
where or when something takes place so
you know for us to have our conversation
I got a little email saying you know
it's going to be whatever 11 o'clock on
whatever is today Tuesday or something
is it you know 11 o'clock on Tuesday and
I needed to be you know at my desk to do
that right so what are the data you need
to give me some spatial data right I
needed to be you know here here we also
needed to give a temporal piece of data
and that was the time and so three
pieces of data delineate where you are
in space one piece of data tells you
where you are in time so that's why we
say four dimensions not anything sort of
more mysterious than that and that's
relevant for events that are taking
place throughout the entirety of the
universe if you want to specify them you
have to say where they take place like
an X Y and Z coordinate a street an
Avenue and a floor number and then you
also have to say when they take place
there's your temporal Dimension four
pieces of data to specify events
so what are what are the dimensions
beyond that and how many dimensions are
we are we how many dimensions can we
prove I don't know so there may not be
any beyond that that's the most
flat-footed straightforward
interpretation of the data but if you
ask somebody like me who spent decades
investigating the extra dimensional
possibility yeah there is interesting
Reasons from the math for taking the
idea of other dimensions at least
seriously we have not seen any evidence
I just need to be straight out about
that for these extra Dimensions but you
know for the past 35 years I've been
investigating theories that suggest that
there are more dimensions of space than
the three that we know about and why
where does this come from well we've
been trying to push forward to realize a
dream articulated initially by Einstein
of having What's called the unified
theory one mathematical theory that
would describe the big things in the
universe the Small Things in everything
in between and that's quite a challenge
Einstein himself never found this
unified theory but in the last few
decades we think we might and again I
need to underscore there is uncertainty
here we think we might have that theory
and within that theory when we study the
math it says that the three dimensions
of space that we know about are not the
only ones
it says that there are at least six
probably seven depending on how you
formulated extra dimensions of space
that we've never seen But six seven
beyond the four yeah okay yeah grand
total of 11 if you if you want to frame
it in that way and we have ideas
Regarding why we've not seen these extra
Dimensions one possibility is they're
they're not big like the dimensions that
we see around us they may be tightly
curled up into a very small shape and
they would be all around us but
just too tiny for us to easily see you
know I can give you you know I don't
know if I can yeah look at this so look
at this this little wire right yeah now
from far away you wouldn't be easy to
see the thickness you'd only see the
length of the wire sure but now as I get
closer and closer it becomes easier and
easier for you to see that there's an
extra Dimension a curled up circular
Dimension that goes around the wire it
doesn't just have length it also has
this circular part A curled up Dimension
imagine that circular part was
incredibly tiny
atomic scale then you wouldn't be able
to see it with a naked eye at all and
all it would look like is one line from
my left hand to my right hand
but if you zoom in
then the circular Dimension becomes more
apparent we think that might be true of
the universe this obvious Dimension
would be like left right back forth up
down three dimensions easy to see the
curled up part might be like those other
seven dimensions that are harder to see
they're all around us but so tiny that
the naked eye are even powerful
equipment that we currently have can't
access them what are we thinking or what
are you guys thinking is in the
dimensions well
thing that you know about in a sense
would be there because everything
fundamentally we learn from quantum
physics is vibrating Fields vibrating
fields of energy the electron feel the
Quark Fields gravitation is described by
a field and these fields can penetrate
these extra Dimensions if they have
adequate energy if they're strong enough
the fields are strong enough so in
principle anything can can probe into
those extra Dimensions it's just a
question of the amount of energy that
the the probe has the universe is
expanding correct that's and it's
expanding
faster and faster yes
but entropy is another fundamental truth
in the universe correct like everything
is essentially leading towards entropy
but yet it's the universe is growing at
an exponential rate so how does that how
how do you Rectify that or do those even
do those even go together as a thought
of how does that happen
they do it's a very intricate dance
between the entropy of the cosmos and
the size and the expansion of the cosmos
at some level you can imagine that there
is nice resonance because
if you think about entropy as disorder
you say to yourself well if a system is
bigger it has greater capacity to be
disordered right I mean if you have a
one bedroom apartment there's just so
much disorder there can be but now if
you've got 10 bedrooms you could have
disorder in all of them you could have
more disorder because you've got more
space
and so you might say the expanding
universe is compatible with an increase
in entropy because now there's more
space to house the increasing disorder
and there's some there's some truth to
it of that way of thinking it's not the
full story but certainly part of the
story but the interesting thing with the
accelerated expansion
is that in a way that would be a little
hard for me to explain fully but I'll
just give the basic idea because the
universe is expanding it faster than the
speed of light that's a crazy idea but
it is it means that there are places out
there Beyond which we can't see because
if once the expansion goes faster than
the speed of light the light can't reach
us
right so
in a sense we are surrounded by a sphere
that we can't see beyond and that's fear
in some sense has entropy and that
entropy in that sphere is generating
some heat within our universe so when
you think about the far future of the
universe and what its entropy will be
like that's the situation that you wind
up analyzing imagining that we are
surrounded by a large sphere that's
coming from The Accelerated expansion
and that sphere itself has a temperature
and that temperature controls the final
entropy of the cosmos if you like this
clip and you want to hear the whole
episode click at the bottom of your
screen